EVERYTHING HAS TO BE POISONED.
B6 WHAT THAT MEANS YOU ARE
IMMORAL SIMPLY.
MARK STEYN WAS ALSO WATCHING
LAST NIGHT AND JOINS US.
THEY DO CARE DEEPLY, WOULDN'T
YOU SAY MUCH MORE DEEPLY THAN A
PERSON LIKE YOU CARES?
>> THEY CARED AT LENGTH.
THAT GUY YOU HAD ON SAYING THAT
MOVIES GIVE A VOICE TO THE
VOICELESS, I HAVE TO LAUGH.
THEY DID THAT ALL NIGHT LONG,
THEY SAID MOVIES GIVE A VOICE TO
THE VOICELESS SHORTLY BEFORE
THEY CUT OFF THE MICROPHONE OF
THE BEST SOUND EDITING GUY
BECAUSE HIS COWINNER HAS GONE
LONG ON HER SPEECH.
SO IT WAS LITERALLY
HYPOCRITICAL.
LISA SAID SHE JUST WANTED TO
HAVE FUN.
A FEW DECADES AGO, THE OSCARS
SHOWS WHERE A BIG DEAL AND THEY
WERE CONVENTIONAL SHOWS OF THAT
TYPE.
THEY'VE GOTTEN RID OF
EVERYTHING, THEY GOT RID OF THE
SONG AND DANCE AND THE JOKES,
THEY GOT RID OF THE HOSTS.
THEY GOT RID OF THE GOWNS.
THE GALLANTS WERE FRUMPY LAST
NIGHT EXCEPT FOR BILLY PORTER
IN, WHAT DID HE CALL IT, A TOXIC
ADDRESS.
HE WAS THE ONLY ONE I WOULD HAVE
ASKED TO DANCE WITH IN THE
POST-OSCAR BALL.
AND ALL THAT LEFT WAS THIS PIOUS
EARNEST VIRTUE SIGNALING, WHICH
I THINK THEY THINK BECAUSE THEY
BOTTOMED OUT AND GOT A LITTLE
UPTICK IN ON THE AUDIENCE, THEY
IN FACT HAVE A CORE AUDIENCE
THAT DOESN'T WANT FUN, TO GO
BACK TO LISA'S WORD, WHICH IS
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE WITH ITS
PIOUS AND BORING VIRTUE
SIGNALING.
AND I WONDER IF IT MAKES THEM
FEEL GOOD.
>> HOLLYWOOD IN SOME WAYS IS
OVERCOME A DIMENSIONING ITS
POWER AND ITS REACH.
I WONDER IF -- THEY HAVE TO MAKE
THESE NOISES.
>> I THINK SPIKE LEE CERTAINLY
DOES.
HE WALKS OUT OF WHAT'S CALLED
THE GREEN ROOM OR AT GREEN DOOR,
AND I THINK MOST OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE ARE READING GLASSY EYED
FROM THE TELEPHONE, AND ONE
THING IS, THAT'S AWFUL PROMPTER
READERS.
THEY ARE DOING IT BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST PART OF WHAT IT MEANS.
WHEN YOU GO UP TO HIS HOTEL
ROOM, THEN YOU HAVE TO GENUFLECT
TO TRANSGENDER RIGHTS OR
WHATEVER IS THIS YEAR'S FACTION.
THEY JUST DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO TO KEEP THEMSELVES IN WORK.
>> Tucker: DID ANYBODY SAY
ANYTHING ARTISTIC, WHICH IS TO
SAY, UNEXPECTED, INTERESTING,
AGAINST THE GRAIN, RADICAL, OR
WAS IT ALL JUST APPROVED
THOUGHTS?
THERE IS NO SENSE OF JOY OR
PLEASURE IN THE EVENT, A GUY WHO
IS GETTING A STATUETTE FOR
MAKING A MOVIE, HE FEELS OBLIGED
TO TALK ABOUT THE OF HIS NATIVE
PEOPLE, IF YOU SERIOUSLY BELIEVE
IT'S AND, IT'S ACTUALLY
TRIVIALIZING OF THAT.
IT'S CONNECTED TO YOU FOR
GETTING SOME CRUMMY AWARD FROM
BEST OF ACTED SCREENPLAY.
AND YOU HAVEN'T FOUND ANYTHING
TO PUT IN ITS PLACE.
>> Tucker: THEY'VE LOST THE
POWER EVEN TO OFFEND ME, THAT'S